and he asked the question that he'd like
to hear the panel's perspective on the
decision by the canadian government to
permit the return of repaired nordstrom
1 turbines to germany a decision that
has frustrated ukraine and many of its
supporters and allies
has the federal government miscalculated
in allowing this exception to its
russian sanctions uh there's there's a
similar question also being being asked
by uh
aaron d'andrea uh who also is asking
similar question but relating to uh just
kind of more of an update that recent
that there was a report that gasprom uh
yesterday told its customers in europe
that it can't guarantee gas supplies
because of extraordinary circumstances
adding to the fears russia may not
restart north stream one pipeline uh
what do we make of this report um and uh
the government of canada has been
subject to criticism over positions of
ship repair turbines north stream too uh
so you know we're we're seeing this you
know pressure from germany uh we
certainly saw what seemed to be at least
support if not pressure from the white
house uh for this decision to happen
weakening of sanctions um
but uh nonetheless no guarantees that
it's actually going to provide gas uh to
germany
perhaps
general clark if you want to start off
with that and we can see if general
petraeus and general hillary would like
to comment on that as well
well we've been watching
the nordstrom issue very very carefully
for a long time and obviously we've been
worried for years about europe's
indebtedness to russia
on the energy front
but i think in in this case we've got
sanctions we've got unity we're trying
to hold nato together i think we will we
will hold europe together
but i think the the key to this is to
understand that you have to have
resilience
you have to bend but not break you have
to absorb the bumps in the road and
still keep the pressure on russia for
the long term and
it does require the art of diplomacy and
compromise and that's what uh president
biden's leadership has brought us in
nato and dealing with the eu
germany's been a real challenge
for years they've cozied up to russia
former german chancellor working very
closely with vladimir putin on many
issues and so it's been difficult
germany believed that its security was
safe and they could just pursue their
economic well-being germany's
transitioning out of that mindset
step by step
you know the hard thing about
about the west if you believe in
democracies is every democracy has its
own internal processes canada the united
states
germany britain
and um
it's it's just the strength of the
people that these democratic systems uh
work from
it's very easy if you're
in russia to deceive yourself and
believe that you can take an issue like
this and break the alliance i don't
think that russia can do this but i do
think that there will be
other bumps in the road where
some relief is given for this issue or
another that helps cement the alliance
together so i wouldn't be concerned
about this i'd be looking down the road
and remember at this point in this
struggle
the military factor is the dominant
factor
if we don't succeed on the military
basis right now then the rest of it
is not going to help ukraine so we've
got to get the assistance in especially
to these territorial defense forces now
that are being called on to take main
battle position
uh up in in the fight in the east
so
um
accept some diplomacy some resilience
some flexibility in the application of
the sanctions it's going to work out
general petraeus
well i'm in a broad agreement with
canada's decision it was a very tough
one
they
had support from the us and germany uh
encouragement we have to
reckon with the realities of energy
provision how important it is
especially for countries like germany
that have
been so heavily dependent on russian gas
over the years
um i'd like to
build on this though a bit uh and really
focus on
an irony of what has taken place because
in trying to make
russia great again what putin has really
done is make nato great again uh there's
a degree of unity in nato now that
hasn't been seen since the end of the
cold war
that was even true in the days leading
up to the invasion i was at the munich
security conference again this year
uh and the unity there uh already and
the invasion didn't start for another
couple of days following the end of that
gathering
that unity is something i hadn't seen
since i was writing speeches for the
sakyar uh during the cold war as a young
major
this has really been quite extraordinary
uh putin essentially pushed
finland and sweden into the arms of nato
uh it will lead to nato expansion this
will make the baltic sea
and largely nato controlled uh sea
uh and so this has truly backfired in
innumerable ways uh for russia
that includes of course the various
sanctions that have been placed on the
russian economy its financial system
putin's inner circle
that includes
sanctions in the energy area
it includes export controls that are
going to make it very very difficult for
russia to
build or replace the systems the
enormous quantity of systems that it has
lost on the battlefield
uh the number of tanks is staggering
that they've lost and again if you can't
get microchips there's no way that
you're going to be able to
build new systems this is why after all
they're going to iran of all countries
to get replacements uh for their drones
that they've lost in great numbers as
well
so again this has been an extraordinary
development uh as general clark noted
the unprovoked invasion of a
sovereign democratic nation
um
we clearly have to be on the side of
ukraine uh in this particular situation
this is the first invasion of that type
since the end of the cold war uh the
rules based order does uh hang in the
balance
um and it is a moment where nato has
come together in an extraordinary
fashion and by and large uh again
uh lead guided uh by the actions from
washington uh in this particular
situation
that said there are going to be very
difficult calls uh i think the issue of
the generator return to uh for uh
nordstrom one uh clearly was one of
those
uh but again i think canada weighed all
of the uh the options the information
the pros and the cons
and ultimately made a decision that i
think was
uh in the best interest really of all
involved because again
if a major country like germany uh is
deprived its energy
uh the cohesion that i've just described
the unity uh that has been truly
extraordinary uh since uh the invasion
of ukraine uh is going to be a potential
casualty as well
uh thanks sean petraeus of course you
could tell that the the stakeholder
advisory council is uh not monolithic
and we have often very different views
on certain things
including this issue but i certainly
welcome that uh general hillary would
you like to comment on on the turbine
question and the sanctions yeah paul
just just a few words really and i'm i'm
a slight bit i think more harsh
on the canadian government decision and
i wish it had been slightly different or
in fact different as simple as that i
think maybe we we are going to see two
things from this
and i'm worried about both number one is
russia is going to see this as a sign of
encouragement
that there will be
uh decisions made that will benefit them
as as we go longer out and and the
second thing i worry about is that we're
now at six point at six months you know
we're in the middle of summer
inflation is rearing its ugly head in
the west people are coming out of the
pandemic and want to travel and the
focus is anything but ukraine
and this decision
to send the turbines back to germany
to send the turbines back sorry
would be seen in in einstein as maybe
the time when we have now
not going like this on sanctions more
and more sanctions to russia but in
hindsight it may be seen as a straw that
broke the camel's back and we may start
to see a relenting
of pressure from nato from the west in
general i hope that that is not the case
but i think we saw after 2014 and the
invasion of crimea and what occurred
that in a very short order
the west pressure the pressure from the
west started to relent
and and russia was not paying the severe
price that it had prior and in this case
i worry in einstein that the turbine
decision
might be the trigger that causes that to
start occurring now instead of going
upwards and onwards with more and more
sanctions that this might be
the straw that caused it to turn
downwards i'll stop there
well if i could just pile on there i i
think that uh they're
inevitably and very complex situations
like this
uh are very difficult decisions uh there
end up being exceptions to every rule in
this case however i think that the broad
trend
uh is one in which the u.s together with
its nato allies and western partners
are examining the supply chains of every
one of the major industries
particularly those that have an impact
on the battle in ukraine the war in
ukraine
and essentially sanctioning those
elements that enable
the various industries through their
supply chains
uh the best example of this is with the
very early export controls on export of
microchips to russia also of course you
have the financial sanctions which
include the freezing
of the 600 billion dollars that russia
stashed around the world thinking that
it would avoid sanctions in that way
but to their surprise those particular
sanctions have not been violated
including by
by china which is the largest holder of
those foreign reserves
so again i i'm quite heartened that the
direction forward is that of continuing
to make these sanctions more
difficult for russia
to continue to make
the supply chains more inaccessible
for russia
but that there will have to be from time
to time
if you will prudent uh
exceptions to the rule uh because you
could lose that unity that is so
critical going forward uh but again a
very very difficult decision to be sure
thanks